frequently those awarding the prize
haven't yet said whether Edward Snowden
is aware he is the recipient Snowden
hasn't been easy to contact while
marooned at Moscow Airport state of
business you good as honor for civil
rights campaigners Snowden's case is a
scandal they say he is being persecuted
like a criminal for acting in the public
interest it's vida and kinder Shay's not
a pedophile and he's not a person who
has committed criminal acts was okay not
a tax evader he's simply a person who
has uncovered some uncomfortable truths
addicted the prize is not only in
tribute to Snowden's whistleblowing it's
also intended to put pressure on the
German government to offer protection to
the former IT contractor Vanessa
Bergersen we would welcome it very much
if Snowden were granted asylum in
Germany or were taken into a witness
protection program so that a genuine
investigation could be undertaken here
in to what's actually going on there
bastard at least I'd say take the ship
but Chancellor Merkel has ruled out help
for Snowden in a brief statement last
week she said he was not eligible for
asylum in Germany